World of Warcraft's mm oh that just
won't won't go down is that and like I
feel like we've been talking about the
death of world of organized for for an
incredibly long time but it's such a
silly thing to talk about like I I think
we say that because it was the biggest
and it still continues to biggest yeah
but when you come down from like 11 or
12 million people playing every month to
now what maybe five six million yeah
like I'm sure they had a bump think
they've stopped talking about how many
subscribe they stop publicly talking
about how many subscribers they get but
I'm sure you still get a pretty big bump
around a big release like this totally
I've million people nothing to shake a
stick out this is the sixth expansion
for this game and I mean it wasn't like
they were dead like there are expansions
for mmos that you know there were some
mo who used to breed em at every six
months or would you know they weren't
very very big but the expansions I mean
burning crusade this game gets a wacom
in 2004 November thousand four I
remember well because we like God
illegal American versions back home so
we could play it three months before
commander up now bc came in 2007 lich
king 2008 cataclysm in 2010 rewrote the
whole map Pandaria 2012 a whole new area
and warlords of draenor back in 2014 and
today legion adding a bunch more stuff
and you played some today and i'm
interested to know what that stuff is
but there's there's a lot and a lot of
it's going to be in-game content the
stuff that's immediate is demon hunter
which okay here the game you can
automatically roll the new hero class
kind of similar to death knight mmm
where it's not a new race it's a new set
of abilities now can jump into at a
specific level i think this one is 98
okay so it gets you really close to the
level that you need to be to experience
new content for legion a new level cap
110 one of the more interesting things
that they've added in our the artifact
weapons so on this you're not you're not
going around you're not looting for new
gear in the info in the form of weapons
you're still getting new gear but you
you choose their you get an artifact
weapon you know based on the world of
warcraft mythos ashbringer Doomhammer
based on your class and then you get to
customize that based on the choices that
you make okay
the based on the quest that you complete
within the Legion content so there's
that sort of take the form of remember I
remember when they added its socketed
weapons for instance in the game is it
that sort of thing where you're like
there are parts of the weapon that
you're sort of specializing or putting
you know I think it does have some
abilities like that but primarily it's
cosmetic okay what you choose you get to
choose how it looks because otherwise
like everybody is going to be getting an
ashbringer and then otherwise every
Asperger would look exactly the same
rights are you to make it your own you
get to choose the question and those
quests let you make it look a specific
way and some of them are really cool
summer whatever yeah did you get a
chance to play some earlier today I
watched Julio play okay cool i am not
cut up my version so i'm still somebody
who buys the physical editions right
they make the best collectors into games
i don't buy a lot of physical editions
of games but you know that just looks so
good on yourself it's ya book sitting
there I worked launched at a gamestop
for a lich king and we did a midnight
launch it cork which is like second
biggest city in Ireland and we had a
line out the door for though for those
ones specifically as well like they just
make great SATs and they look right
beside each other as well yeah they line
up really well they've been consistent
with it and if I didn't come in though
ah I did pre-order it yeah and I got a
note from amazon this morning saying
we're gonna we have to delay shipment of
this sometime between September 28th and
october 2050 so while so I'm gonna screw
this i'm just gonna go buy it on best
buy and i pulled up and like oh no it's
cold out all night every related like oh
crap yeah so you can't just go and buy
your key because the interesting thing
now is that i think is that all of the
old expansion packs are no free yes
that's yes you can experience all of
that well let's see yes you can you
don't have to pay extra for that kind of
ice yeah she was not subscribed into it
yes you still have to pay for a
subscription in World of Warcraft but
that stuff it can also level for free up
to 20 I think okay right which is like
so there's a little bit of that crack a
little bit of that that first taste and
the power leveling stuff of course name
is built into our as well so fast like a
level 20 you get you get to level 20 in
just a couple hours yeah that's one of
the reasons I think it's free is like
you can might as well get your
characters up to 20 it's so much faster
than you know back in back in the day of
vanilla wow like that took that was a
feat for sure you played some Wow as
well haven't you yeah I think I only
played about like
15-20 hours total an orc hunter and yeah
I think I got to around level 20 does I
sound right for that amount of time or
no probably like 30 maybe I just
remember everything and I was playing
with myself I don't when I play those
kind of games I kind of aside from like
destiny i play that for the coop
purposes but wow I was always just a
very solitary thing for me me too and I
played the game for years like I you
know I played off past bc and I guess
yeah I was before Lich can i sort of i
dropped off and put every single
expansion pack that came out i would go
back so like I love to play in Cataclysm
when I first came out I did what pandari
as well I guess I didn't so much for
general but i was i was looking forward
to doing with this but it does sound
like most of the content here is end
game stuff right if I go to the store in
the room for it's not gonna be super
different I feel like what yeah the
world itself is not gonna be that
different but I think if you skipped
Draenor like I did run it that it does
feel like a different kind of game I
think dren ores when they introduced a
lot of the graphical upgrades and all of
that so yes you're right so all the
in-game cinematics stuff is like totally
alien to me like I've not seen much of
that at all like I think the game itself
just looks better it's still not
comparable to some of those Korean MMOs
like those are some gorgeous looking
game and the Mo's it didn't come out 12
years ago well it holds it really well
that cartoony art style was such a great
choice in something in creating a game
that lasts that when you look at it
today and you you don't think that this
looks dated that it doesn't look like it
it doesn't look like a piece of craft
and it's like no it's made its stylized
and it fits the world in that game
they've created like wind waker on this
Elvis years like this I'm going to
always look good that's why I've been
playing diablo 3 pretty consistently
since it like 2012 and released was it
and uh I on PC and ps4 and I don't think
that'll ever look too dated i mean i
played diablo 2 still sometimes that
looks dated but that's a completely
different artists hours diablo 3 like
the closest I've gotten to like I'm
sticking with Blizzard for like a super
long time is diablo 3 honestly just with
the updates they are introducing like
the cube like all the juice riffs that
was pretty huge adventure mode was huge
when reaper of souls came out and I mean
there's one thing you can say about
visit is that there we were seen with
overwatch as well but like consistently
wow is that they've done a good job of
trying to retain people like the
drop-off we're seeing for instance in
games like destiny where people are
coming back every time there's an
expansion back I mean that
the peaks and valleys exist in WoW but
they've managed to attack if they've
retaining 5 45 million people that's
quite amazing and they have that core
you have people who i'm sure played
nothing but wow and that's just their
go-to game and it's always been their
go-to game and they even having those
peaks and valleys like you still have
here's your core here's your base the
people that are gonna keep coming back
to it and then people like me that will
go in like oh there's an expansion
here's some new stuff I'll go in and
experience it we don't necessarily have
time to commit all of our yeah gaming
time to just one game but it's it's
something enough to draw you in and you
have that core super friendly super
encouraging audience who will help you
along like so many times when I get in
the game like there are just people who
are higher level who just want to help
you out and yeah i'll show you i'm going
to do these things it's the kilt like
complete opposite of what you here with
no but it's like you have legends hit up
that RPG server as well just make sure
you do you know you speak elvish or
whatever or don't talk about Donald
Trump in general barons chat and they
kick you out donald drumpf it's actually
in it yeah sure Anna dwarvish yeah and
I'm gonna yeah just make some sort of
troll out of it yeah so there you go
world warcraft legion the latest
expansion pack for warcraft out today
and yeah it seems like it's i don't know
from the cursory looking at this and
from hearing what you're saying about
who you're playing it does look like
it's mostly for people who are have been
playing World of Warcraft or maybe got
to the end of end game stuff and wanted
to get more content there I mean it's
you can't you can't I don't even know if
you can make a game at this point and
say we're gonna introduce new people to
push your workout let's go point it's
such a convoluted and complicated thing
I'm like if you're new and you want to
play wow like go play wow yeah like you
don't need those like you've got 10 12
years of amazing many levels and quests
and content i mean i mean like and
they've stream lighted it's so easy to
get into that now and see like well is
world of warcraft for me the expansion
is not gonna convince you you know just
try it out play those first 20 levels
and then and hopefully you have a friend
who can kind of help guide you because
it is still like I don't think it's
unfriendly I think it's friendlier now
than it ever has been but it's
definitely nice to have someone who can
encourage you in and let you know you're
on the right path for sure there you go
and let us know what you think in the
comments below did you play wow in the
past did you have you had your interest
piqued again by Legion are you gonna
jump in or is enough for you let us know
in the comments